all right 3 minutes now we after to the
top of the hour the number one story
most of the issues the most this issue
mostly likely number one in your house
is illegal immigration in America the
breakdown of our border we always focus
on Texas and Arizona we cannot for
forget about California the second video
very similar to what we saw a couple of
days ago you have an operation now where
these uh legal immigrants take this boat
they Beach it in La Hoya if you haven't
been to San Diego it is probably the
nicest City in this in in San Diego it
is rich it's upper class I mean these
Cliffs are unbelievable if you don't hit
a seal on the way in you'll be surprised
uh these guys Beach it there's a cars
waiting for them and they go running in
uh they are now gone yeah that first
video you saw the most recent one shows
that boat with suspected illegal
immigrants landing on the San Diego
beach and then the last week video we
saw of the boat full of the undocumented
migrants they were landing on the beach
in San Diego too and they were running
into this wealthy La Hoya neighborhood
most of the houses there the average
house is like more than $2 million you
can see it's a beautiful residential
area but this County spent $3 million
caring for illegals they're allotting
another 3 million last year over 300
migrants were moved into the San Diego
Airport because the shelters there ran
out of room this is the largest border
city in California right and this
channel is one of the only places you're
going to see these images uh Bill maluan
essentially got that video right there
this is the new stuff this was Tak you
know who who took this a guy named Jack
uh and he was out there in in uh San
Diego with a GoPro he's a apparently a
lifelong San Diego resident and he took
these images obviously what's going on
in addition to uh essentially beaching
the boats and it's becoming more and
more common is these Smugglers these
human Smugglers are stealing a boat
because it's not their boat they can't
buy a boat and then do that it that
doesn't make business sense so there're
stealing boats doing that uh last week
Angley when you were talking about the
La Hoya situation uh that particular
when they ran into that upscale air uh
area naturally just like Californians
Good Samaritan swimmers swam out to pick
up the trash that the illegals had left
behind and a lot of the trash included
fuel cans that were leaking into the
water but this is just a new way of
getting the migrants who pay thousands
of dollars per head in some cases tens
of thousand into the United States those
are what you call gotway
uh those are you know those are like the
people we don't know if they've got
backpacks full of fent we just don't
know but it's more and more common all
right uh by the uh by the way good to
know we we're running out of fighting
age men uh almost everybody that comes
in here filling up our Migrant Center
all young men who are running for their
lives the ones that actually give their
story and again what are they doing here
why aren't they staying in their own
country but in California that not can
be even be pursued in San Diego they're
releasing a lot of these migrants into
the the neighborhoods they said from
October to December of last year 2023
the average on average they were
releasing 637 per day that doesn't
include the ones that cross over
illegally and get in the cars and and
get away and by the way huge gang
problems there a lot of them go right
from one gang to the next gang my
brother-in-law lives right there on the
water right next to the tracks and uh
it's a problem it is a significant
problem meanwhile uh we've been talking
about the migrant situation last week
when we flew out of New Hampshire we
wound up taking off from the airport uh
Lawrence and I were at Boston Logan last
week and and uh lawence we were talking
about and you're in Boston right now we
were talking about how Boston Logan is
being used to house migrants today is
the last day they're going to do that
they got a lot of bad publicity and then
now they're moving them someplace else
right yeah they they not only are moving
them they have moved them and and
according to our law enforcement sources
they moved them in the middle of the the
night M and if you look at the door
behind this it may be hard for our
camera guy Nate the Great to actually
see it there is a sign on the door that
says not open to the public the
interesting thing about that guys the
public is paying for this and nothing
Paints the picture more than when you
look at the poverty rate here in Boston
it's at 177% and this community the
Roxberry Community it's over
28% so you got a lot of the residents
that are frustrated not because they're
not compassionate to my migrants and
they they don't understand people wanted
a better life they're saying they're
currently struggling right now trying to
make end to me and their tax dollars are
going to provide for illegal uh migrants
guys yeah but they're not putting them
in nice places they're not going to put
them in the rich section they got to put
them in the working class section
because rich people don't want illegal
immigrants they just want to say they're
welcome here but not near them right
Lawrence that's the agitation when you
talk to the black and Ino Community that
are here in this country legally they're
saying why are they still considered the
bottom of the barrel when it comes to
these uh politicians and of course you
know the people with the money are
saying no we don't want that M meanwhile
they're donating to all the campaign
saying that they're so compassionate but
when push comes to shove um they want
something different and and you know
when you talk to the residents out here
as well uh when you talk about their
struggle and everything thing their kids
don't have a quality education we
already talked about the poverty so
again what are they going to do about
this and are they going to fix the
communities first before they start
providing for the migrants that's yet to
be determined and it's happening
everywhere remember few weeks ago we did
the story in Brooklyn where it wasn't
one of the best neighborhoods in
Brooklyn wasn't the wealthy area they
told the kids don't come to school we're
going to use your gymnasium on the
second floor to house migrants because
it was cold and of course it's really
cold
uh Lawrence is going to be there all
morning long thank you very much
Lawrence for going back up there so they
going yeah they going to rockberry where
45% of the population are black 28% are
Hispanic and Latino and 14% are white so
don't put them in the nice areas because
then there might be a Martha's Vineyard
moment where suddenly people realize the
illegal immigrants have come home to say
to say hello and they don't want to meet
him I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis